nfc east
with mike mccarthy there
setting aside everything that went wrong
in green bay and the under achievement
while he was there he had a year out of
football he was exiled i feel like he's
viewing it differently i feel like he's
appreciating it more i'm with you how
much does he change that ceiling on a
team that on paper is talented but when
it's time to play the games over the
past several years it's been mixed
results this is really probably the only
team i'm picking to go to the playoffs
that had a dramatic change in the
off-season you know and and again i
think i did it because like what you
just said the team's talented and i
think they got more talented in the
off-season with a guy like cd lamb and
even in the draft and you know the
roster you just can't find too many weak
spots on their football team you can
question maybe a spot or two in the
secondary but i just look at that and
then you know yeah mike mccarthy is new
there so there's new things going on
certainly but he's a super bowl winning
coach been to the playoffs a lot you
know three nfc championship games so he
is kind of a proven commodity there and
i think he is the kind of guy that's
gonna be worth a win or two this year
you know his teams are always tough
they're always detailed i always
complained about his lack of you know
creativity on the offensive side of the
ball he seems that he self-scattered
thyself to get better at that along with
keeping kellen moore so i'm picking the
cowboys to go to the playoffs they're
one of the few teams that had a change
that i'm doing with but i just think
between that roster the offensive
especially and enough difference makers
on defense that i just couldn't leave
them off
you know we had cam newton talk recently
about a match made in heaven between him
and the patriots i mean if we're talking
about lack of creativity on offense mike
mccarthy and the cowboys are a great
match too at least the bar is low in
dallas when it comes to offensive
creativity so if he's going to have this
epiphany if he's going to change his
ways uh that this is the perfect place
for him to do it and and you think about
all the jobs that were available last
year
which job you know the browns have
talent right but the cowboys they got
zeke yeah they got dak right they got
marty cooper right they got michael
gallup they had cd lamb fall into their
laps in round one the defense is a work
in progress and who knows what mike
nolan's going to do with that but yeah
we had peter king on the show the other
day suggesting aldon smith is a
candidate for defensive player of the
year i think a performance somewhat
lower than that level will still be a
nice bump for the cowboys defense so
look i believe in the cowboys this year
i think this is one of those years where
i'm not going to fight it i'm not going
to resist it i'm going to accept the
fact that the theme with the star on the
helmet is going to live because look i i
kind of you know what's good for
football it's kind of good when the
cowboys are
middle of the pack ish and that you've
got that that exasperation that comes
from are they going to get it turned
around are they fine you know because of
their profile this idea that they're
constantly stuck in mud makes them more
interesting they're less interesting
when they're good because people are
always going to be interested in them no
matter what if that makes any sense at
all but i think this is one of those
years where they're going to fulfill
their promise they're going to be good
and i think the sky is the limit for the
cowboys i agree i'm with you you know
elite units are always an important part
of a football team you know whether it's
an elite position group or elite units
and dallas has an elite unit they're
offensive side of the football
i mean i you you put you could put it up
against anybody anybody i i mean really
you could go to toe to toe with kansas
city in a lot of ways now i know i'd
probably pick kansas city but still when
you talk about gala all the names you
mentioned and then arguably one of the
best offensive lines in football and
that running back and i think zeke's a
little pissed off with the way he was
perceived after last year and all that
and then i think mike mccarthy gives
them an edge and now their defense with
mike nolan is not going to line up in
the same two defensive uh you know
formations play after play i i i do i
like dallas and uh i think they're going
to win the nfc east
i interviewed zeke the other day and i
tried to i tried to push his buttons to
get him going because he tweeted
something in july that he is pissed off
1800 rushing yards yards from scrimmage
excuse me 1357 rushing yards and and
people say he had a down year well he
did based on his stance
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports